let's go next to Mike from Massachusetts
Mike from Massachusetts welcome to the
program what's on your mind today
hey David thanks for having me pleasure
um can you hear me all right yeah I can
hear you fine
awesome
um so my
um uh so obviously with everything going
on in the country lately like you know
especially especially on like you know
the front of like you know lgbtq rights
well you know Tennessee just bad gender
affirming care I think this for minors I
think Mississippi did recently too or
yes or something like that but
um anyway there's a lot and plenty of
other topics as well things just don't
look awesome at the moment
um so it's you know I was looking into
kind of how in the 2020 election and the
2022 election it seems that younger
voters particularly gen Z as they're
becoming a voting age now seem to be
changing the electorate the face of the
electorate
um and I came across this uh it's not a
report or maybe more of a study from The
Brookings Institute that they updated in
2020 that kind of project how
you know project how you know with Baby
Boomers getting older and j and z
getting older and just where the
Republican and Democratic Party stand on
certain social issues yeah how they
project that the electorate is going to
change and how various states are going
to change political leaning-wise right
over the next decade or so and I know
maybe this is a little naive to say but
the date even the most conservative
friendly model from that report is
exceptionally optimistic looking for the
Democrats
so it's kind of a two-part question one
do you believe that all these
demographic shifts and the continued
demographic shifts that a lot of people
seem to be portraying coming down the
line with Gen Z and the diversification
of Voters yeah do you think those are
genuine reasons to be optimistic going
forward for the next decade or so you
know I I do think so but at the same
time it's been 12 years at least of
people saying the demographic shifts in
Texas are going to make it a red State a
blue State the demographic shifts in
Georgia are going to make it a blue
State and it's like well Georgia did
vote for some Democratic senators that's
true but continued uh Republican
governors in Texas I mean yes the 2020
presidential was as close as it has been
in decades but it's definitely not a
blue state so on the one hand the the
predictions and the models seem sound
but I'm also aware that people have been
talking about this for 12 years and it
hasn't yet happened so so I I think it's
plausible that it will eventually happen
but I don't think it can it's a strategy
for Democrats anytime soon to just rely
on demographic changes
no I understand and um I think like yes
people have definitely been talking
about certain States particularly Texas
shifting from red to blue yeah for quite
a while now
um it seems like we are kind of finally
reaching a point like I guess I would
use the term inflection point yeah where
you know the oldest Baby Boomers and I
don't mean to be morbid about this but
the oldest baby boomers are only a year
or two away from the average life
expectancy in this country
um
so that voting base is going to start
declining in gen Z which is by every
poll we can find overwhelmingly liberal
and Progressive no I agree I agree it's
just a matter of when and so in the
meantime we've got to do the best we can
to win elections the the normal ways
which is
um making the right case on issues doing
the campaigning doing the work etc but
at some point I see it as hopefully a
bonus that is coming which is the
demographic advantages
oh absolutely they definitely need to
keep campaigning to win people over they
can't just rely on these changes but it
will make things easier and I guess the
second part of my question is if these
projections end up being even relatively
accurate I mean
what exactly would be
a possible approach for the Republican
party to remain politically relevant
they're already doing it it's just try
to steal the elections I mean that what
that's why they're already doing it
they're already losing on policy with
the electorate that we have and so the
approach is let's make it harder for
people to vote let's say we won even
when we didn't win let's look at purging
voter rolls they're doing all that stuff
they're just going to do even more of it
no 100 it's just I feel like that stuff
can only get you so far well we'll see I
mean let's let's see let's see how far
it gets them in 24 and then go from
there
fair enough fair enough
um
like I said it was just something that
like I came across and I was like is
this too good to be true or is this
genuine reason for optimism in the next
decade or so so you know I mean let's
just hope that the ship the shifts keep
happening and the Democrats keep not
completely shooting themselves in the
flood all right Mike from Massachusetts
very much well said always good to hear
from you
one of our sponsors today is Bluetooth a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month's supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence when
it's time all you have to do is take a
short quiz on their website a licensed
doctor approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of Bluetooth tablets are made in the
USA the entire process is just a few
clicks go to bluetooth.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code Pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping